[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paris einen schönen guten abend
und willkommen was heute alles wichtiges
und sport passiert ist erfahren sie von
norbert lehmann tonschön guten also
schauen wir auf die großen themen in
dieser sendung
es hat bei dem booster impfungen
millionen menschen könnten sie sich noch
holen aber die impfstellen sind
überlastet
gewalt an der grenze zwischen polen und
belarus präsident lukaschenko
telefoniert mit kanzlerin merkel
und alarm im all wegen möglicher
kollision mit weltraumschrott muss die
ss gleich zwei mal geräumt werden
die korona zahlen steigen immer weiter
wie die politik sie wieder zum sinken
bringen will entscheidet sich am
donnerstag denn da soll im bundestag das
neue infektionsschutzgesetz beschlossen
werden zudem gibt es ein bund länder
treffen zu corona viele bundesländer
wollen aber nicht bis dahin warten und
verschärfen bereits jetzt ihre regeln
für ungeimpfte julia schröter
unterwegs mit der polizei in bamberg
unterwegs in besonderer mission die
beamten kontrollieren ob die korona
regeln eingehalten werden seit heute
gilt in bayern in fast allen bereichen
zweig zutritt nur für geimpfte oder
genießen sie halten und fragen wir
kontrollieren die gäste ja auch wenn ab
und zu mal leute dabei sind die
vielleicht nicht so gut finden aber es
ist wichtig dass alle an einem strang
ziehen und mitmachen die inzidenz steigt
und steigt immer mehr bundesländer
ziehen die zügel an setzen vor allem auf
die 2g regel in berlin etwa gilt sie
seit gestern und baden württemberg ab
morgen auch das besonders von corona
betroffene thüringen will zwei gehen und
schnell umsetzen die landesregierung
steht in der verpflichtung jetzt die
maßnahmen systematisch so durchzusetzen
dass es auch zwischen den einzelnen
landkreisen keine verwerfungen mehr gibt
dass es dort auch keine keine freien
entscheidungen mehr gibt sondern die 2g
vorschriften in die verordnung so
aufgenommen werden dass sie möglichst
zügig flächendeckend umgesetzt werden
all das um möglichst eines noch zu
verhindern den kollaps der
intensivstationen heute sind laut die
wie intensiv register
3280 cupid patienten in den sieg
medizinischer behandlung 90 mehr als
gestern
vor diesem hintergrund berät sich lieber
morgen die ministerpräsidenten runde mit
der kanzlerin bayern fordert dafür vor
allem einen einheitlichen kurs
was es braucht ist zweig flächendeckend
in deutschland es braucht eine klare
booster empfehlung die schon bereits ab
dem fünften monat stattfindet wir
brauchen eine impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen auch das muss rasch
verabschiedet werden es ist der zweite
corona winter und wieder ist der
handlungsbedarf groß
vielerorts also wieder mehr
beschränkungen sie wollen wissen was in
ihrem bundesland gilt 2g oder 3g dann
finden sie bei uns online einen ständig
aktualisierten überblick und auch
weitere infos jederzeit auf unserer zdf
heute
schauen wir uns die korona lage in
deutschland in zahlen seit tagen steigt
die inzidenz auf jetzt 3 112,4 das rkw
meldete
32.000 48 neuinfektionen 10.000 216 mehr
als vergangenen dienstag empfohlen wird
aktuell eine auffrischungsimpfung für
neuneinhalb millionen menschen denn laut
lka lässt der impfschutz nach einem
halben jahr nach allerdings haben dafür
bisher nur vier millionen die booster
impfung erhalten und 5,5 millionen sind
noch nicht drangekommen peter böhme
berichtet
anstehen für die impfung lange schlangen
wie hier am imk bus in dortmund oder
auch in bielefeld wo der
arbeiter-samariter-bund vor allem die
auffrischungsimpfung anbietet unabhängig
vom alter impfärzte prüfen jeden
einzelfall
ich sehe wie hoch das ganze geht so und
ich möchte in meiner heimat fahren nach
regensburg geht das ganze gerade richtig
durch die decke in bayern das land
energie er hatte solche mobilen
infektionen in der letzten woche
angekündigt zusätzlich zu den impfungen
bei den ärzten sechs monate nach der
zweite impfung soll jeder eine dritte
impfung bekommen können allerdings laut
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
zunächst nur über 70 jährige daran hält
sich hausarzt matthias schlotter meyer
aber nicht
dass gar nicht durchführbar in der
praxis einer hausarztpraxis jetzt zu
unterscheiden noch wer ist jetzt vor wem
dran es gibt ja auch keine offiziellen
rangfolge also sind wir bei first come
first ich glaube wirklich so viel und so
schnell wie möglich dritte impfung
durchführen es gibt verschiedene
möglichkeiten die dritte impfung zu
bekommen bei haus- und fachärzten in
verbliebenen impfzentren und neun
stationen in bussen und in kliniken
allerdings läuft die booster impfung
hierzulande langsam an daran sind die
länder die diesen staat vollkommen
verstolpert haben und zwar grundsätzlich
weil sie die impfzentren abgeschafft
haben und weil die niedergelassenen
praxen überhaupt nicht vorbereitet sind
harsche kritik an der politik die
reaktion es nimmt ja jetzt der fahrt auf
das sehen wir auch in den zahlen auch
das vor den impfzentren sie schlangen
gebildet haben die leute wollen die
auffrischungsimpfungen wir haben in
bayern auch normal eine klare botschaft
dass sie schon nach fünf monaten möglich
ist dass wir da auch die haftungen
mitübernehmen noch aber sind die termine
knapp nicht mal für die über 70-jährigen
sagen die patientenschützer würde es
derzeit reichen
was tun gegen korona verantworten lohnt
sich auch ein blick auf andere länder
die vieles anders machen und manches
besser in europa sieht es bei der
incident so aus im vergleich zu
deutschland weisen einige länder höhere
zahlen auf niedrigere gibt es in
skandinavien aber interessanterweise vor
allem auch im süden etwa in italien und
in spanien
die ja noch zu beginn der pandemie mit
am stärksten betroffen waren nun also
läuft es dort besser ein grund die hohe
impfbereitschaft aus spanien berichtet
an arendt aus italien andreas postel
wer mit der booster impfung an der reihe
ist bekommt eine benachrichtigung per
app oder sms pflegepersonal lehrer und
risikogruppen erhalten seit wochen eine
auffrischung habt dezember folgen
bereits die über 40-jährigen geimpft
genesen getestet in bus und bahn gilt 3g
ebenso wie landesweit am arbeitsplatz
bereits vor vier wochen hat die
regierung trage diesen stärkeren hebel
angesetzt firmen die den grünen passen
nicht kontrollieren droht eine
geldstrafe angestellten ohne pass droht
lohnausfall kroner test sind
kostenpflichtig denn die italiener
sollen sich impfen lassen was sie auch
tun einerseits hat das sogenannte
bergamo trauma mit den vielen toten in
italien die impfbereitschaft deutlich
vergrößert andererseits ist die breite
regierungskoalition von mario draghi in
der lage frühzeitig strengste maßnahmen
durchzusetzen und das selbst gegen zum
teil heftigen widerstand von wenigen
aber lauten impfgegnern die mehrheit der
bevölkerung steht hinter den maßnahmen
der regierung so impft sich italien aus
der krise auch wenn die infektionszahlen
wieder zu nehmen gibt es weit weniger
schwer kranke als noch vor einem jahr
von landesweit 9000 intensivbetten sind
momentan nur 475 belegt so konnte
italien sogar corona patienten aus
bayern aufnehmen
in spanien lässt sich das leben genießen
ganz ohne nachweis ob geimpft oder
genießen cafés und restaurants verlangen
ein solches zertifikat nicht denn fast
90 prozent der über zwölfjährigen sind
ohnehin geimpft die erste corona welle
war ein schock und wir haben begriffen
dass die impfung der einzige weg zurück
zu einem halbwegs normalen leben ist
in einer epidemie wie dieser muss man
sich im klaren darüber sein dass man das
für die gemeinschaft tut
ich habe gerade die dritte impfung
bekommen zusammen mit der
grippeschutzimpfung
gesundheitszentren übernehmen in spanien
die ärztliche grundversorgung von jung
bis alt das schafft vertrauen impfgegner
gibt es so gut wie keine
hebel zum erfolg ist auch die
weitreichenden digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens die erleichtert die
verteilung der impftermine und der
impfstoffe und führt dazu dass niemand
durchs raster fällt auch jetzt nicht bei
der dritten dosis mehr als zweieinhalb
millionen dieser booster impfungen
wurden bereits verabreicht spanien
wappnet sich für den winter
zurück nach deutschland für die ampel
parteien geht es in den endspurt in der
kommenden woche wollen spd grüne und fdp
im koalitionsvertrag vorlegen die
botschaft der drei generalsekretäre
heute wir kriegen das hin wo man sich
geeinigt hatte und welche streitpunkte
ist noch gibt darüber wurde nichts
bekannt
nikolaus woche soll olaf scholz zum
neuen kanzler gewählt werden
die cdu versucht sich unterdessen für
die oppositionsrolle aufzustellen und
sucht dafür einen neuen parteichef
nachdem bereits noch kanzleramtsminister
braun sowie der bundestagsabgeordnete
röttgen ihren hut in den ring geworfen
haben ist auch ex unionsfraktionschef
märz offiziell im rennen und hat heute
dafür sein team vorgestellt märz bewirbt
sich bereits zum dritten mal um den
cdu-vorsitz teenager
friedrich merz will es nochmal wissen
zusammen mit zwei die gerade frisch in
den bundestag eingezogen sind wird er
die cdu überzeugen und mit neuer tonlage
es wird mit mir hier keinen rechtsruck
in der union geben es wird keine achsen
verschiebung in der union geben mit mir
soll es ein klares profil geben und ich
möchte dass alle diejenigen die sich im
weitesten sinne als christdemokraten
verstehen wirtschaftsliberale sozial
politisch engagierte menschen genauso
wie wertkonservative in dieser cdu eine
politische heimat finden als
generalsekretär schlägt mit mario zuvor
46 jahre alt ehemaliger senator für
gesundheit und soziales in berlin
wir haben eine immer größere schere von
arm und reich das kann uns nicht kalt
lassen und die cdu muss die soziale
frage stärker ins auge den posten einer
vize generalsekretärin will märz neu
erschaffen das soll christina stumpf
werden verwaltungswirtin aus baden
württemberg selbstbewusst gegen eine
frauenquote
heute 34 natürlich als ständiger gast
der jungen und auch ohne quote bislang
sehr gut durch qualifikation und
kompetenz vorangekommen deswegen bin ich
jetzt jemand was er gegen die
frauenquote ausspricht dieses quoten
thema müssen wir noch mal besprechen und
behandeln das werden wir sicherlich dann
nach der entscheidung über die
vorsitzendenwahl tun da gibt es also
noch einiges zu klären sowie die cdu
klären muss er parteichef werden soll
röttgen braun oder märz ergebnis mitte
dezember
als absolut frustrierend bezeichnet
verdi-chef wernecke die tarifgespräche
im öffentlichen dienst heute hat die
gewerkschaft den druck erhöht und das
personal an unikliniken zu warnstreiks
aufgerufen wie hier in leipzig verdi
fordert fünf prozent mehr lohn für die
beschäftigten mindestens aber 150 euro
im monat ende november steht in potsdam
die dritte verhandlungsrunde an
der streit um aus dem 2 geht weiter die
ostseepipeline ist zwar fertig
gestelltes russisches gas fließt wird es
aber noch dauern
die bundesnetzagentur das verfahren zur
freigabe auf eis gelegt und zwar aus
formalen gründen die betreiber firma
müsse zuerst nach deutschem recht
organisiert werden heißt es von der
behörde
der kreml dringt auf eine schnelle
zertifizierung kritikerinnen und
kritiker des projekts dagegen warnen vor
einer wachsenden abhängigkeit von
russland
und sie fühlen sich in ihrer kritik
bestätigt durch den konflikt um
geflüchtete mit dem russischen
verbündeten belarus an der belarussische
polnischen grenze kam es auch heute
wieder zu gewalt die kanzlerin hatte
gestern erstmals seit seiner
umstrittenen wiederwahl mit machthaber
lukaschenko telefoniert
dafür wurde sie vom außenpolitischen
sprecher der grünen nouripour scharf
kritisiert peter theißen über die lage
vor ort
es sind dramatische bilder von
grenzposten kurs nizza migranten werfen
steine auf polnische soldaten
zerschneiden grenzzäune versuchen mit
aller gewalt auf die andere seite zu
kommen in die eu die polnischen
sicherheitskräfte antworten mit
wasserwerfern nach polnischer lesart
werden hier die nato und die eu grenzen
verteidigt
wir sind darauf vorbereitet dass dieser
hybride angriff auf belarus mit dem
einverständnis russlands noch monate
dauern könnte also auch während der
schwierigen zeit des winters
der angriff sei zurückgeschlagen heißt
es schließlich am nachmittag die
wortwahl ist drastisch als stünden auf
der anderen seite nicht migranten aus
dem nahen osten sondern eine armee in
dieser aufgeladenen stimmung kommt es in
polen nicht gut an das noch kanzlerin
merkel mit dem belarussischen diktator
lukaschenko telefoniert und ihn damit
vielleicht wieder ein stück hoffähig
gemacht hat zwar sehr polen informiert
worden aber zu spät die regierung in
warschau befürchtet wohl dass die
bisherige gemeinsame front der eu gegen
lukaschenko risse bekommt
unterdessen kritisierte lukaschenko
polen erneut scharf für den einsatz an
der grenze während boulahrouz humanitäre
hilfe leiste viele polen mit
wasserwerfern auf migranten so die
propaganda aus minsk die verschweigt
dass erst belarussische politik diese
krise hervorgerufen hat die
spannungsgeladene situation an der
eu-außengrenze hat sich mit dem heutigen
tag erneut verschärft
vor dem europäischen gerichtshof haben
polen und ungarn erneut eine niederlage
kassiert so sei die machtfülle des
polnischen justizministers mit eu-recht
nicht vereinbar er könne richter hoher
strafgerichte einfach abberufen das
untergrabe die unabhängigkeit der justiz
im blick auf ungarn urteilte der bgh das
land verstoße gegen eu recht weil
flüchtlings helferinnen und helfer
kriminalisiert würden
das verhältnis zwischen den usa und
china hat sich in den vergangenen jahren
nochmal verschlechtert
nun haben erstmals die beiden
präsidenten beiden und ski bei einem
video gipfel miteinander gesprochen drei
stunden lang ihre differenzen wie beim
streit um taiwan bei menschenrechten
oder beim handel konnten die staatschefs
aber nicht beiseite legen so wurden auch
keine konkreten beschlüsse gefasst aber
immerhin weitere gespräche angekündigt
die usa und auch deutschland werfen
russland vor die sicherheit der
internationalen raumstation iss zu
gefährden moskau hatte einen seiner
eigenen alten satelliten abgeschossen
weltraumschrott der gefährlich werden
kann die erdumlaufbahn wird allgemein
immer mehr zur müllhalde mehr als 100
millionen trümmer umrunden inzwischen
den globus selbst millimeter kleine
teile können dabei große schäden
verursachen markus wolsiffer
wir planen jetzt alle luken bis morgen
geschlossen zu halten
das ist ein funkspruch der es in sich
hat die nasa fordert die astronauten der
iss auf sich umgehend in eine
sicherheitskapsel zu begeben vor wenigen
tagen war der deutsche matthias maurer
ist fröhlich empfangen worden jetzt
dieser zwischenfall grund für den alarm
hunderttausende trümmerteile die
us-regierung wirft russland vor
absichtlich weltraumschrott hinterlassen
zu haben
russlands gefährliches und
verantwortungsloses verhalten gefährdet
die langfristige nachhaltigkeit des
weltraums russland habe so die us
regierung mit einer anti satelliten
rakete einen alten sowjetischen
satelliten beschossen einer
machtdemonstration
unangekündigt die iss-crew hat den
vorfall unbeschadet überstanden moskau
wies die vorwürfe empört zurück und
spricht lediglich von einem
ungefährlichen test das ist heuchelei zu
behaupten dass die russische föderation
eine gefahr für friedliche weltraum
aktivitäten darstellt dafür gibt es
keine belege
zurück bleiben tausende trümmerteile ein
problem für unsere kommunikative
infrastruktur wie etwa gps
weil solche kleinen teile auch große
satelliten durchaus zerstören können und
dann natürlich weiteren noch mehr
kleinere fragmente erzeugen völlig
gebannt ist die gefahr für die iss noch
nicht immerhin die astronauten können
künftig mit ausweichmanövern reagieren
weil die größeren trümmerteile
rechtzeitig zu orten sind
komme zum tennis da hat alexanders wäre
erfreut eine niederlage einstecken
müssen bei den atp finals in turin gegen
den titelverteidiger daniel medwedew ein
packendes match auf augenhöhe das der
weltranglisten zweite aus russland mit 6
2 3 6 7 7 6 gewann es wäre fatal noch
chancen aufs halbfinale
daniel medwedew in der weißen hose
startet besser in dieses match ihm
gelingt ein frühes break zum 2 0 es ist
das zweite aufeinandertreffen der beiden
innerhalb von zehn tagen zuletzt in
paris gewann der russe so etwas wie
schweres angstgegner nach 38 minuten
dann zwei satzbälle für mit wert jetzt
63 für den weltranglisten zweiten wir
springen in den zweiten satz zu einer
schlüsselszene im tie-break fußfehler
mit werden der russe wirkt sichtlich
genervt alexanders wäre fad an sich
gearbeitet bleibt ruhig und sichert sich
den zweiten satz mit 7 zu 6 die
entscheidung im dritten durchgang erneut
tie-break ein wahrer krimi zwei
matchbälle kann es wäre es abwehren doch
nach gut zweieinhalb stunden heißt der
sieger wieder einmal mit wer hier
gewinnt wer am donnerstag gegen den
polen lukasz steht auch er im halbfinale
italien hat die direkte qualifikation
zur fußball wm 2022 in katar verpasst
nach einem enttäuschenden 0 0 gegen
nordirland gestern an muss die
mannschaft nun in die playoffs hier
warten starke gegner wie portugal
schweden oder polen auch 2018 fand die
wm
ohne italien statt nach einem umbau der
mannschaft dann dieses jahr der triumph
bei der em die azzurri sind muss bei
europameister
guan yu so erhält als erster chinese der
formel 1 ein stammcockpit der 22 jährige
startet nächste saison bei alfa romeo an
der seite von valtteri bottas so fährt
seit 2009 10 in der formel 2 und nicht
kurz vor saison in der in der
gesamtwertung auf platz zwei
basketball nationalspieler dennis
schröder hat in der nba den boston
celtics in einer hitzigen schlussphase
gegen cleveland den sieg gesichert der
braunschweiger erzielte sechs seiner 14
punkte beim 98 92 erfolg bei den cable
ist in den letzten beiden spielminuten
und bestätigte damit seine starke form
in den vergangenen fünf partien punktete
schröder jeweils zweistellig
allerhand das war es um sport und
bewegung kommt morgen auch ins wetter
zumindest in norddeutschland erst fällt
wie dann wird es windig und später kommt
die sonne heraus mehr dazu gleich von
katja vorne fahren das heute-journal
können sie um 21 45 sehen mit claus
kleber
[Musik]
guten abend auch heute gab es mal wieder
eine dicke hochnebeldecke die bereitet
sie sich hier von der ostsee bis zum
atlantik aus aber jetzt kommt ein
bisschen bewegung ins wetter sehen sie
hier in diesem hohen wolken die von
nordwesten herankommen und auch an der
aufgelockerten bewölkung nordwestlich
der britischen insel das ist eine kleine
kaltfront heute aber gab es schon ein
paar sonnenfenster hier im erzgebirge
und auch in berlin kann man kurz die
sonne zum vorschein was sie hier sehen
das sieht zwar aus wie eine wolken lücke
ist aber in wirklichkeit nur der
schatten der wolken auf der
hochnebeldecke bei vier bis elf grad
heute nacht sinken die temperaturen an
der küste an der ems und am rhein auf 5
grad ein grad werden es in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und dazu ist es wieder
sehr nämlich es gibt hochnebel seltener
etwas nieselregen und dann kommt diese
kleine kaltfront heran und die breitet
sich morgen weiter richtung südosten aus
sehr viel regen bringt sie nicht mit
aber der wind nimmt zu und dann reißen
die wolken an der nordseeküste mal
wieder auseinander und sie sehen die
sonne sonst aber bleibt es trüb mit
wieder viel nebel und die temperaturen
dazu liegen bei fünf bis elf grad und
ganz ähnlich geht es in den nächsten
tagen weiter im norden eher mit regen im
süden er drückt guten abend